- Oh my gosh.
Sorry we're running late.
It's because I sprayed
my eyeball with perfume.
- I heard, it happens.
- Have you ever done
that with like cologne?
- I can't say I have, fortunately enough.
- Just lie to make me feel better, Marcus.
- No I have, every day, honestly.
I just, yeah, no. I heard
about that.
- That sucks.
I'm so glad you're back.
And Rob and I were talking about dogs.
Do you have dogs? Are you a pet lover?
- I'm a pet fiend.
Well that made it sound
a lot more extreme than it is.
- I know, I like it.
- But I do have a dog
that, awe look at him.
- Oh my gosh.
- His name is Odin. He's a big sweetheart.
He's a Rottweiler.
Yeah, he's three years old.
And, yeah he's the love of my life.
Love that dude.
- Look at those snuggles happening
right now.
- I know.
He's the greatest. I miss him.
He lives with my parents.
I got my own apartment,
whatever, you know?
I'm 23 now.
(audience cheering)
- So really your parents got a dog?
- Yeah, they have a dog now.
Which is like, it's a rough situation.
I feel like a lot of, I swore
I would never be that kid.
I was like, I'm responsible.
I'm gonna take care of this. I did it.
We had another dog named Zeus
unfortunately pass away recently.
But Zeus was a beagle, and I begged
my parents for years to get a dog.
And when we finally got
one, I was waking up
at 6:00 AM, I was feeding him.
I was going to all the appointments.
I was doing everything.
- Yeah.
- I was making sure.
But with Odin, I slacked off.
In my older age, I've gotten weak.
- That's 'cause you're young twenties
and you're just having fun.
- Exactly. I'm wildin'.
- Yeah, that's kinda what
you're supposed to do.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So how's your new year going?
Are you the guy that like
makes resolutions and like keeps them?
- No, I have such a weak will.
- Yeah, me too.
- I made the resolution to eat healthier.
That did not stick.
I had In N Out yesterday on
the way back to an event.
- So it did not last long.
- It did not last long at all.
- In N Out is worth it.
- It's worth it.
- It is.
- Animal style, I get a three by three
animal style, no pickles, light tomato,
animal fries, extra well done.
- Nice.
- With grilled onions.
- I hope this shows up
- I'm from LA.
- at your door later today.
Like people see this.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Like we know what he likes.
- You know guys, wink wink.
Nobody send it to me.
- And I like diamonds.
(audience laughing)
- They're nice.
Well, congratulations.
- Thank you.
- Grown-ish just got
picked up for another season.
That's awesome.
- Yes, season six
here we come, yeah.
(audience applauding)
- It's such a trip.
'Cause you've been a
part of this whole thing
for so long, like a decade, right?
- Yeah. It's been, yeah.
I feel, I always joke with people
I'm like, when you've seen as much
as I've seen the ripe age of 23.
No, but I've been, yeah we've been
doing it since I was 13 years old.
Junior is a fantastic character.
Wouldn't want to be on this
journey with anyone else.
And I'm -
- It's so rare, though, that you get
that character and get to like, grow up
in that character and
you are, that's so rare.
- Yeah. Yeah, it's crazy.
I think, I mean, I credit our writers
and being able to evolve the
character over the years.
He hasn't remained stagnant.
He's kind of continued to grow.
- Yeah.
- And people have
watched him grow up in
front of their eyes.
And I think that's part of
the success of the show, so.
- Absolutely. I agree.
Well we were talking about
your dog earlier, or dogs.
Is it, and I'm sorry about Zeus.
That sucks losing a pet.
- Thank you.
- Is it true that you are an expert
at naming dog breeds
like based on the photo?
- Yes. I'm pretty good.
Like, I can name most dog breeds.
I'm confident.
- I really wanna challenge this knowledge.
- Oh boy.
- Exactly.
You shouldn't -
- I shouldn't have spoke up.
- You shouldn't tell us things
here.
- Yeah, I shouldn't
have said anything.
- You shouldn't you
shouldn't tell us things.
Because I want you to play a game.
Will you play a game with me?
- I will.
- Okay, okay.
If you said no, it still is gonna happen.
(audience applauding)
- Okay.
- All right, let's do another
quick commercial break everybody.
Be sure to watch grown-ish on Freeform.
The second half of the
fifth season debuts today.